[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive uh it's time
to see what's making the headlines
tonight with the political editor of the
daily mirror pippa carrera and the
political editor of the sun harry cole
they will be with us uh from now until
just before midnight so let's have a
look at what is on some of those front
pages
russia on a collision course with west
over ukraine says the guardian with the
uk set to respond with tough sanctions
the financial times reports president
vladimir putin is poised to recognize
eastern ukraine's two breakaway regions
by redrawing borders
the daily telegraph has president putin
warning of bloodshed and reports that
russian forces are being sent into
ukraine to keep the peace in breakaway
areas
on covid restrictions the metro says
it's now over to you as the prime
minister urges people to take personal
responsibility for self-isolation
the daily mail reports it's been 701
days since we were first told to stay
home now boris johnson throws off the
shackles
and the eye also leads with the
scrapping of covid restrictions pay for
your own tests is part of the new covid
plan it says
uh and there is a reminder that by
scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
uh all while watching us uh and we are
joined uh tonight by pippa crera and
harry cole thank you very much to both
of you for being with us this evening
let's start with the story dominating
most of the front pages tonight and the
front of the financial times certainly
uh putin recognizes two breakaway
republics in eastern ukraine and now
this news that we touched on there in in
the telegraph mentioned that uh putin is
sending peacekeeping well i say
peacekeeping in inverted commas uh
troops to donetsk and to luhansk harry
cole is this war
it's an incredibly fast-moving situation
um what we have is
president putin saying he's sending in
these so-called peacekeepers to a uh
a so-called republic uh breakaway
republic what is actually he's
suggesting is he's starting to send in
russian troops to a sovereign country
now
boris johnson joe biden uh could not
have been clearer uh boris johnson said
to the sun just two weeks ago if one
still toe cap russian boot crosses uh
one's toe cap of one boot crosses into
sovereign ukraine territory then a steel
trap of uh of sanctions will spring down
will we wait and see whether that really
does happen tonight i fear
that uh the slightly sort of messy
way in which pugen has done this might
actually fracture what was already a
pretty um
pretty wobbly western coalition i have a
horrible feeling some european countries
uh some of those other ones who haven't
been quite pulling their weight will be
wobbling tonight france already saying
that uh they want their talks uh planned
for thursday with president putin and
his officials to carry on going ahead
that doesn't look to me like a united
steel trap coming down swiftly on
president putin as it should be well the
guardian funnily enough uh uh saying a
similar thing to you there putin puts
russia on collision course with the west
over ukraine doesn't necessarily say how
united or not that west might be
pippa
how embroiled now do you think the west
will get if this does become a war what
level of involvement will valet will
will the west allow itself to have given
the hangover of afghanistan last summer
well that's the big question what
happens next and
up until this point there has been a
fairly unified response beyond you know
with the hope that the diplomatic
solution could still
um exist uh support for the french
attempting to set up more talks
but both the u.s and the uk as harry
rightly says being much more cautious
about the prospects of of that being
successful nevertheless they were all
attempting to find diplomatic roots um
there's been many conversations between
western leaders and
vladimir putin in recent weeks um but
it's sadly looking increasingly likely
that that's that's not going to happen
and now the question is do they um
support
if if the if that steel cut boot does
step over into either the next donesk or
lehansk um russian troops despite the
messy way that this has come about does
the west react in the way that it has
promised it that it will do it does that
involve economic and military support
for the ukraine although of course
britain has said that there would be any
british troops on the ground does that
involve the crippling sanctions that
we've been promised by list trust in the
uk by the us and indeed tonight by the
european union as well can they unite
and do that together as one rather than
a sort of a sort of a disparate um
selection of measures
which are opposed against different
aspects of the russian regime do they do
they boot out some of these kleptocrats
from from western cities you know we
have to see um the resolve is currently
there whether that they're able to to
put that political resolve into
political action and crucially as harry
says do it together is another question
tonight i'm afraid certainly and i
wonder what uh harry you think about
that those sanctions uh they have been
gradually beefed up over the last uh
weeks are there any form of economic
sanctions certainly that could actually
do anything that would make any
difference with putin at this stage
well yeah look they can they can drive a
massive wedge between putin and his
oligarch class you can make life
extremely difficult for
rich wealthy russian business people
around the world especially in london
you can kick off companies off the
london stock exchange russian link
companies russian companies themselves
who you know have been had a free run in
london for too long now whether it's
whether that's going to have any effect
on putin depends on his state of mind as
people are split into two camps is he
actually being cold ruthless and logical
here or is he lost lost his mind a
little bit you know everyone's got a
different opinion on that but frankly it
feels to me like all the warning signs
have been there that actually you know
i'm pretty sure the message he's been
given privately to
to diplomats uh and politicians visiting
russia and talking to his officials is
frankly you know you can you can stick
you can stick your sanctions i don't
care this is about russian pride this is
about a restoration of the russian
federation's greatness this is that mad
speech he gave today about how he
intentionally said ukraine is a made-up
country it doesn't exist we're going to
do what we want it does feel a little
bit like we're slightly howling at the
wind and putin respects force and you
know i honestly think this situation
wouldn't have happened if he hadn't been
given inch after inch after inch over
the last few years first of all the
americans were sanctioning under donald
trump any efforts by uh by gazprom to
build the north nordstrom 2 um
gas connection into into the european
union they the white house incredibly
firm line against that tried to shut it
down biden comes into office lifts those
sanctions allows it to come forward now
we've got all this dither about whether
the germans what would crap what would
count as enough of an incursion into
ukraine before the germans would pull
the plug on that incredibly um
controversial um gas project of course
sorry to interrupt you but we are short
on time uh i just want to bring some
breaking uh news that we've had from uh
number 10 uh saying that the prime
minister will share a cobra meeting
tomorrow at 6 30 in the morning to
discuss those latest developments in
ukraine also to agree and coordinate the
uk uh response including a significant
package of sanctions to be introduced uh
immediately well let's bring that back
uh to uh pippa and harry pippa uh on
that i mean if we go back to our front
pages the photos of putin uh in that
long rambling speech that he made on the
front of many including the daily
telegraph warning of bloodshed as he
moves his troops
we were just talking about those
sanctions what do you make of that that
the prime minister will be chairing a
cobra meeting tomorrow at 6 30. do you
think there could be something new to
come from that sanctions we haven't
heard of yet investments foreign
investments that might be
changed well this trust suggested
earlier this evening that we'd start to
see um the sanctions
details of the sanctions be put into
place from tomorrow so presumably this
meeting is um is sort of getting to
grips with how they're going to do that
obviously the last couple of weeks
they've gone through the legislative
process so that there is a package that
is tougher than the existing sanctions
regime that they had at the disposable
disposal is ready to go
and i think we can probably expect
depending on what happens in the next
couple of days uh in the region in
ukraine um for
to see that that being imposed is
obviously the u.s has already said that
in the two breakaway um
regions of ukraine which
donetsk and luhansk that it's bringing
in sanctions and preventing u.s
investment and business being done in
those um and
and also i think we'll we should expect
more sanctions focused on moscow and the
kremlin itself obviously britain has got
um a long history of of dealing with uh
russian aggression through these means
ever since salisbury poisoning but it
has to go broader than that really i
think when it becomes when you get to
the point of uh of the sort of
incursions that we're we're seeing
threatened right on europe's doorstep i
mean if this does erupt into a
full-scale conflict it is as boris
johnson and others have said likely to
be incredibly bloody in the biggest
scale conflict um uh in europe since the
second world war and that's not
something that anybody wants to see so
any measure which can be taken whether
it's sanctions whether it's military
support economic support rather for for
the ukraine whether it's any deterrence
at all that they can place on putin um
it's got to be it's got to be worth a go
yeah pippa thank you um as as ever the
papers struggling to keep up with this
there is more breaking news a phone call
now between uh prime minister boris
johnson and the ukrainian president
vladimir zelensky
uh in which it was said they talked well
they both condemned uh russia's uh move
and uh the prime minister said he would
explore uh sending extra defense support
to ukraine uh after putin recognized the
independence of the regions of donetsk
and luhansk
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now the political editor
of the daily mirror pippa carrera and
the political editor of the sun harry
cole thanks both for staying with us
let's go straight i'm afraid that
ukraine hasn't left us much time to talk
about the other big story of the day the
coveted restrictions lifting front page
of the metro prime minister now it's
over to you urging personal
responsibility uh pippa is this throwing
off the shackles of coveted restrictions
do you think or is it too much too soon
well i think you know life is returned
to more or less normal for a lot of
people in england and these are sort of
the final touches to the restrictions
that the tory wright had been pushing
for the legal restrictions that were
still in place about self-isolation and
then also the decision to um to withdraw
free testing from april the first i
think the problem for the prime minister
is is that while of course many people
are ready to move on um the
scientists and in fact the prime
minister himself made clear tonight uh
the pandemic is not yet over and there's
it's a bit of a dispute it seems about
how quickly you can press the button to
restart some of these to these results
and these protections and the testing
regime um should a new variant a worse
variant appear in the future bristol
seems convinced tonight that you are
able to out would be able to do that
although um even the ons survey has been
scaled back
which is sort of the pre-bit of
the key bit of surveillance if you like
on on the spread of future variants um
and of course there are concerns that um
while he's asked people to take use
their personal responsibility um to uh
to take care and
to be cautious he hasn't given them the
tools to do so because obviously the key
one of those um is uh is testing the
ability to know whether they they are
positive or not pepper i want to give a
quick word to harry on this uh as well
we've got about a minute left not even
uh what do you make of it
i think like covert has slightly become
a bit of a culture war a bit like brexit
and i'm afraid it's really depressing
but you know the people that hate boris
johnson are screaming tonight that he's
going to kill millions and
and the people you know the people that
want their freedoms back
uh are delighted somewhere in the center
there's most normal people trying to
wonder what to do i think the sort of
the public has slightly voted with their
feet on these things things feel like
they've got back to normal this is only
a natural progression from that i'm
getting i'm so sorry to have to cut you
off we'll be talking about this
in the next hour do stay with us here on
sky news